الان ونحن داخل مشفى
الشفاء قام قلال
بالقاء القاء القنابل
الدخانيه الشام الذي قام بعمل ربكه وتوتر
بين هال المرضى والجرحى
والنازحين في داخل
المستشفى الطفل الياس الذي لم يبلغ من
العمر سو ثلاث سنوات او وربما اقل لم يستم
من هذه الحرب ايضا كانها حرب على الاطفال
في قطاع
غزه نحن الان في قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ
داخل مشفى الشفاء كميه المعاناه التي
يعانيها المرضى في هذا المستشفى وفي هذا
القسم كبيره بسبب انقطاع السبل عن مشفى
الشفاء بسبب الحصار للمستشفى ومحيطه من
قوات الاحتلال
والياته الان ونحن داخل مشفى الشفاء
وخصوصا في قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ راينا
هذا الطفل الذي لم يبلغ من العمر تقريبا
ثلاث سنوات لاربع سنوات بترت رجله بترت
قدمه بسبب
الح كيف تصاوب ايش صار معك احنا كنا
ماسحين طلعنا من مدرسه الدرج برض كان مشكل
علينا خطر كبير لانهم قصفوا المدرسه اللي
احنا قاعدين فيها فلجان الى مف
الشفاء حتى يعني قلنا انه مكان امن لانه
دخلوها اليهود وبعد هيك مش ح دخلوها هان
مكان الامان مناش غير الشفا تم عمل عمليه
لهذا
الطفل لحتى الان العمليه شبه مش ناجحه
لانه الجرح مفتوح والدبابيس اللي في في
الجرح فكوا قبل ست ايام من العمليه
لم يكتفي الاحتلال بالطفل جود حاله كحال
كل الاطفال الذين نراهم
الان
استشهد جده وجدته وابوه وامه واعمامه
اربعه كمان 32 32 نفر طلعوا
هول كان محروقين يعني وهدول اللي طلعوا
منهم هو كمان
شاب 29 سنه هو اللي باقي من بقيه اخته انا
عمه ابوهم
[موسيقى]
كمان